so can we uh discuss the details
so first of all which psychedelic are we
talking about and maybe can you talk
about
the 15 people and how the study ran and
what you found
yeah yeah so the drug we're using is
psilocybin
and we're using um moderately high and
high doses of psilocybin
and i should say this about most of our
work these are not kind of museum level
doses in other words nothing
even big fans of psychedelics want to
take and go to a go to a concert or go
to the museum
if someone's at burning man on this type
of dose like
they're probably going to want to find
their way back to their tent and zip up
and hunker down
for you know not be around strangers
yeah and by the way uh the the delivery
method so
psilocybin is mushrooms i guess
uh what's the usual is it
edible is there some other way like how
people are supposed to think about
uh the the correct dosing of these
things because i've heard
that it's hard to dose correctly uh
that's right that's right so in our
studies we use the the pure compound
psilocybin so it's a single molecule
you know a bunch of molecules and we and
we
give them a capsule with that in it um
uh
and so it's just you know a little
capsule they swallow what
people when psilocybin is used outside
of research it's always in the context
of mushrooms
um because they're so easy to grow
there's no market for synthetic
psilocybin there's no reason for that to
pop up um
that the
the the high dose that we use
in research is 30 milligrams
body weight adjusted so if you're a
heavier person it might be like 40 or
even 50
milligrams um we have some data
based on that data we're actually moving
into like getting away from the body
weight
adjusting of the dose and just giving an
absolute dose it seems like there's no
justification for the body weight based
dosing but
i i digress um generally 30 40
milligrams it's a high dose
and based on average even though as you
alluded to there's variability which
gets people into some trouble
in terms of mushrooms like cilantro
cubensis which is the most common for
species in the illicit market in the us
this is about equivalent to
five dried grams which is right at about
where
right where mckenna and others they call
it a
a heroic dose you know this is not
hanging out with your friends going to
the concert again so this is
a real deal dose even to people that
like really you know just even to
psychonauts
and even we've even had numbers yeah
people that yeah
that's a great cosmonaut you know like
for psychedelics yeah
going as far out as possible but even
for them even for
even for those who've flown to space
before
right right they're like holy [ __ ] i
didn't know the orbit would be that
yeah far out you know like or i i
escaped the
orbit i was in interplanetary space
there
so these folks in the the 15 folks in
the study they're not there's not a
question of
uh dose being too low to truly have an
impact
right right very out of hundreds of
volunteers over the years we've only
seen a couple of people where there was
a
mild effect of the of the 30 milligrams
and
who knows that persons their serotonin
they might have lesser
density of serotonin 2a receptors or
something we don't know but it's
extremely rare for most people this is
like
like something interesting is going to
happen
you